Ashley Graham has a shirt here but it
seems like she forgot to put it on for
the cover of Maxim she's already the
first curvy model to lay on the cover of
the Sports Illustrated Swimsuit Issue
and now it seems she is ready for world
domination
Ashley shared her plan with our lauren
zima the dream of taking over the world
I do want women to understand that they
can take over who they are she's become
a role model for real women everywhere
but it's that bombshell body that's her
moneymaker what was your reaction when
you got the call from Maxim well I got
so excited and of course I started
looking up like every Maxim cover that
recently came out and it's so classy
it's so beautiful
part of that world domination plan
includes becoming a fitness guru and her
own talk show the Ashley Graham child
there's so many different directions I
could take my talk shop reality show
talk show I think more like docu serious
and type thing yeah I mean the really
truly sky's the limit the 28 year old
has been married to cinematographer
Justin urban since she was 22 they have
a bicoastal marriage and committed to
abstinence until they tied the knot I
made the decision to not have sex with
my husband before I was married because
I didn't want to get lost in another
relationship and now I'm married because
I want to be not because I feel like I
have to be and I'm having sex with a man
because I want to be and not because I
feel like I have to make her and we
actually met at church in New York City
and now he lives in LA and you live in
New York how do you guys do the
long-distance thing we have a rule we
don't go longer than two weeks without
seeing each other and it's absolutely
fabulous I love it so we just we need in
LA or New York we made in Paris Miami
it's pretty sexy because we waited till
we were married to have sex there was
already such a sexual tension between us
that we just wanted to basically pounce
on each other how does he react to you
doing some of these sexy photos he loves
it he he affirms me all the time unless
know how sexy and beautiful I am
favorite compliment that your husband
gives you when I wake up in the morning
and you know you've got the crusty eyes
and everything and he still tells me how
beautiful I am and it's kind of great
knowing she's just like us when it comes
to splurging what's your vice boot
french fries and mac and cheese
in the same meal I am so with you there
on the French fries that is my advice
too
now Ashley told us that she wants to
have a baby in the next few years and
she wants to develop her own line of
curvy maternity wear